arriva
momento nella vita
ci si inizia a sentire insoddisfatti
come schiacciati
coperti un verso il basso e questo cade
quando ogni traguardo che tagliamo non
si manifesta così soddisfacente come ci
aspettassimo ogni obiettivo non riesce a
completarsi così corriamo e curiamo
verso il prossimo
ed è proprio mentre corriamo che ne
siamo a temere che il tempo che c'è
stato concesso non sia sufficiente per
sentirci veramente realizzati e che la
realtà è che si sia destinati a correre
senza alcun meta per sempre chi di voi
non mi conoscesse ecco con tutta
probabilità quasi sicuramente avrà
sentito uno dei miei ultimi singoli
uscito l'estate scorsa che è super
classico faccio rapido quando a 12 anni
anche se per un certo periodo di tempo
della mia vita decisi che non avrei più
avuto nulla a che fare con la musica
tuttavia partire dal 2016 ho
ricominciato questa mia attività
musicale applicando adesso una sola
regola quella che non avrei bruciato le
tappe e che quindi cosa che non avevo
fatto in precedenza mi sarei concesso il
mio tempo
ecco questo non è esattamente facile nel
momento in cui si fa il rap
il musicista in maniera più ampia
l'artista perché spesso queste
professioni prevedono un grande
coinvolgimento del proprio ego e ancor
più spesso fanno rima con ambizione e
quindi mentirei se non sostenesse il
fatto che fin dalle prime volte al
microfono fin dalle prime volte sul
palco il successo e tutto ciò che ne
deriva non fossero treme obiettivi mal
essermi approcciato in maniera più
adulta e da più adulto a questo lavoro
ma sicuramente aiutato comprenderne e
alcuni aspetti che mi erano sfuggiti in
precedenza dopo la pubblicazione del mio
primo album ne ho pubblicato una
riedizione una ri pak come consuetudine
nell'industria musicale odierna e
all'interno di questa nuova versione di
come uccidere un usignolo potete trovare
il brano che avete sentito in apertura
che si chiama spleen che come suggerisce
il titolo si riferisce a quel senso di
perenne mal essere descritto da
baudelaire e che il poeta contrappone
invece all'idea che è una condizione
invece positiva di benessere
ecco questo spin fa sì che l'uomo compia
una corsa perenne verso i propri
obiettivi convinto che questi
sono rappresentare l'ideale ma ogni
volta che questi obiettivi vengono
raggiunti così dimostrano privi di
valore alla radice di ciò sta al tempo
che l'uomo sa essere una risorsa
limitata e quindi finita e questo fa sì
che l'uomo nella sua corsa la sua corsa
si faccia sempre più affannosa sempre
quasi più dolorosa e paura che il tempo
finisca senza che l'idea sia stato
raggiunto
ecco quando ho pubblicato come uccidere
un usignolo per la prima volta nella mia
vita mi sentivo di esser salito sul
treno giusto su preso alla stazione
giusta l'orario giusta la coincidenza
giusta eppure i miei colleghi miei
coetanei con i quali avevo condiviso
anche una parte del percorso erano
esplosi qualche mese prima di me ed
erano già lanciati nella ionosfera e
questo mi faceva sentire in difetto nei
loro confronti mi trovavo nella
condizione descritta da baudelaire avevo
raggiunto un obiettivo ma non ero felice
ecco gli anni di cui sto parlando sono
gli anni tra il 2016 e il 2017 sono anni
che nel mio ambiente nella musica urban
italiana vengono ricordati con una certa
ironica nostalgia come se fosse un e
rafah sono hanno effettivamente che
hanno portato una profonda rivoluzione
nel mercato discografico italiano sta
con questo cambiamento è stato la causa
e non l'effetto di un qualcosa di molto
più grande che stava e che sta avvenendo
tuttora in tutto il mondo
mentre infatti abbiamo cominciato a
staccare la vita dell'uomo e il suo
scopo dall'idea dell'essere unicamente
produttivi
ecco quindi abbiamo una riscoperta del
fitness healthy food del tempo da
dedicare a noi stessi ecco dall'altra
parte ogni piccolo tassello anche il più
piccolo che compone le nostre giornate è
basato su un solo principio quello
dell'immediatezza qui abbiamo spunta blu
che ci indicano perfettamente il tempo
che intercorre tra la ricezione di un
messaggio e la sua effettiva risposta
abbiamo ordini e consegne con lassi di
tempo sempre più brevi
come se il bisogno di ricevere ciò che
desideriamo venga prima del desiderio
stesso tutto ciò che sta succedendo in
questo momento nel mondo segue una sola
regola
qui e ora tutto e subito
stiamo vivendo un momento chiave delle
nostre esistenze il momento più
importante delle nostre vite e che non
tornerà mai più
almeno fino al prossimo secondo
ecco tornando all industria musicale
oggi esce musica ogni settimana fino a
qualche anno fa però i primi passi al
mondo di un nuovo album richiedevano
tempi più dilatati la produzione la
promozione la distribuzione di un disco
avevano bisogno di tempi meramente
tecnici più lunghi e quindi poteva
succedere tranquillamente che un singolo
ci mettesse anche un paio di anni prima
di esplodere un paio di anni dalla sua
pubblicazione
giusto il tempo di raggiungere le
persone oggi non è decisamente così come
dicevo ogni settimana esce nuova musica
ogni venerdì abbiamo playlist
perfettamente aggiornate con tutto ciò
che c'è di nuovo che eliminano ciò che è
vecchio e tutto ciò che è vecchio e
tutto ciò che è uscito settimana scorsa
la musica viene trattata come un
prodotto i tempi della domanda si
accorciano e quelli dell'offerta devono
tenere il passo
lo streaming ha reso accessibile una
quantità potenzialmente illimitata di
musica gli ascoltatori e quindi bisogno
da parte degli ascoltatori di ascoltare
nuova musica si fa sempre più impellente
è la situazione un po descritta da
baudelaire no l'obiettivo viene
raggiunto e se si dimostra privo di
valore ricomincia la corsa se oggi
venerdì stai ascoltando nuova musica
tempo di venerdì prossimo avrei
ricominciato a correre i tempi delle
relique si accorciano e quindi se un
artista affermato se un big
fino a qualche anno fa pubblicava un
album di tre quattro cinque anni da oggi
può concedersi il lusso di pubblicarlo
ogni due
magari dopo un blockbuster e non va
sicuramente meglio a un artista
emergente ecco un artista emergente
dovrebbe pubblicare un album
hanno magari un ep ogni sei mesi uscite
lampo però significano anche molto
spesso carriere lampo prima parlavamo
del 2016 come se fosse una era fa un
tempo un'era musicale durava 10 20 anni
oggi dura 2 3 anni e quando uno era
musicale se ne va molto spesso porta via
con sé anche buona parte dei suoi
protagonisti
questo si traduce in una maggiore
pressione sugli artisti e in un minor
tempo da poter vivere da poter dedicare
a vivere esperienze che possano
effettivamente ispirare e determinare un
esigenza di scrittura a fronte di una
richiesta qualitativamente altissima del
prodotto finito che comunque verrà
sempre paragonato a tutto ciò che è
uscito in precedenza senza considerare
il mutamento della realtà discografica
avvenuta nello stesso lasso di tempo
ecco questa è una visione quasi spavento
re della quasi catastrofica della cosa
però nel tempo si è dimostrato gli
ascoltatori anche gli artisti
addirittura hanno dimostrato che i
nostri gusti hanno bisogno
molto spesso di un qualcosa di un po più
ragionato e che chi contro
intuitivamente si prende il proprio
tempo alla fine vince sempre
è il caso di persona l'album più venduto
del 2020
pubblicato nel 2019 e che marrakesh ha
impiegato quattro anni per realizzarlo
quasi un'eternità per i tempi di oggi
ecco per intenderci quando è stato
pubblicato l'album precedente di
marrakech status in italia nessuno aveva
ancora sentito la parola trap una parola
che sembra essersi fagocitata tutto
quello che ha a che fare con la musica
urban nel nostro paese ormai il pubblico
le gi delle cose in due o e popolo e tra
quando vogliono fare i diversi dicono
andy in dio trat
ecco al contempo anche i colossi
dell'industria cinematografica hanno
cominciato a ridisegnare i propri tempi
ea rallentare se pensiamo a better
console lo spin off di breaking bad cosa
pensiamo anche a demanda lorean il primo
prodotto seriale dell'universo star wars
hanno cominciato sono ritornati alla
pubblicazione settimanale delle proprie
puntate
questo cosa significa che il pubblico ne
parla e non ne parla più
per quei due giorni richiesti per vedere
le otto puntate che che compongono la
stagione ma per tutto il tempo della sua
pubblicazione che a volte può
significare anche mesi
un'eternità a confronto a a quello al
mordi e fuggi a cui ci stavamo abituando
ho aperto parlando di super classico un
un pezzo un mio successo personale che
mi ha aperto porte che fino a qualche
mese fa pensavo fossero totalmente
sbarrate per me dopo la pubblicazione di
super classico e del suo album
l'album all'interno del quale contenuto
gemelli
ho cominciato a ricevere premiazioni
anche per tutta la mia produzione
precedente
alcuni miei pezzi del 2016 vengono
certificati singolo de oro singolo di
platino disco d'oro e disco di platino
dalla fini oggi dopo cinque anni e che
significa che sono sopravvissuti bene al
passare del tempo è una cosa
assolutamente non scontata oggi tra con
una parte del pubblico e addirittura una
parte degli addetti ai lavori pensa che
in questo momento io dovrei spremere
questo successo finchè c a cavalcare
l'onda finché dura ma la mia esperienza
mi insegna che per cavalcare bene
un'onda bisogna imparare a valorizzare
il proprio tempo se vogliamo che ciò che
ascoltiamo segni i nostri ricordi
indelebilmente dobbiamo far sì che la
musica che ascoltiamo derivi da
esperienze che hanno segnato
indelebilmente ricordi di chi quella
musica la scritta concludo quindi
dicendo che dobbiamo se vogliamo che la
musica sopravviva il tempo e segna il
tempo dobbiamo ricominciare ad imparare
ad aspettare che chi ha scritto quella
musica abbia vissuto del tempo di
qualità grazie